[Music]  have you heard that molden district  council wants to hear from you about how  it should tackle the issues challenges  and opportunities the district faces  from growth and development  [Music]  by law the council must have an  up-to-date local development plan that  allocates enough land for building new  homes businesses community facilities  and setting aside green spaces  recent changes to national planning  policy means that the current local  development plan needs to be reviewed  now  the council also wants to hear about how  it can get new developments to work  better for the district including things  like design  flood risk climate change and protecting  the things that make the malden district  special  the council would love for you to take  part and help shape its local  development plan review  to get involved go to  www.molden.gov dot uk forward slash  issues hyphen and hyphen options between  the 17th of january and the 14th of  march 2022